hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about the 7 lessons that I've learned
from many weight loss failures now I've
been a practice for 29 years worked on
about 40,000 different people so I had a
lot of interaction with people and you
learned so much from your clients it's
incredible so I guess that's why you
call it a practice so you're practicing
and they're a patient so they have to
have patience and we have a waiting room
but at a great opportunity to find out
what works and what doesn't work ok so
I'm gonna go through the seven lessons
that I've learned ok so let's start with
number 1 fruit okay so here's the lesson
that I learned about fruit you don't
want to use fruit if you're trying to
help people lose weight now I'm talking
about someone with a slow metabolism I
pretty much approach everyone from the
viewpoint that have a slow metabolism
why don't we do that because we're gonna
get results with every type of case ok
but if you're operating off this idea
that everyone has a good metabolism and
they don't have insulin resistance your
results are going to be very very poor
ok so tiny bit of fruit could block a
lot of fat burning for a day or two
ok lesson number two snacks now I used
to recommend so-called healthy snacks I
used to consume healthy snacks between
meals was indefinitely at night at the
time I thought it was ok because it was
healthy it wasn't junk food but I found
out through trial and error that that's
really bad advice because the snacking
increases insulin just because anytime
you eat you trigger insulin okay and
this data is right in Guyton's
physiology I must have missed it when I
originally studied that but the point is
that if you cut out the snacks that one
action creates huge benefits so it's a
very important lesson that I learned if
you want to get results with stubborn
weight especially if you have a slow
metabolism or a thyroid issue or
whatever ok so even if it's healthy you
want to do everything to avoid the
snacking between the meals that's why we
do intermittent fasting all right number
three I used to recommend it's called a
liver enhancement and it was in my first
book that you would go very low protein
you know even like no protein
for first two weeks bad advice I was
thinking that that would be toxic to the
body and we're gonna detoxify the body
by not giving protein but people crash
and burn they had a lot of blood sugar
issues because our bodies need amino
acids to rebuild and repair so if you
cut it out too low or not enough you're
gonna actually cause a lot of problems
with hair loss loss of muscle especially
for two weeks so we want to have a
moderate amount of protein okay we don't
want to do it a protein detox we don't
want to do a no protein anything number
four they used to recommend that your
breakfast was the most important meal of
the day it was in my first book and I
learned that it's actually bad advice
why would you want to screw up the fast
all night long then you break the fast
with the breakfast okay and then you're
gonna be hungry an hour later push
yourself closer and closer to lunch and
not eat until you're hungry and
eventually skip the breakfast I find
that a lot of people do very very very
well not just with their weight but
further with their health because you
want to go a longer period of time with
fasting because you're coming out of
sleeping okay you're already in this
fast ride the way if you have momentum
you don't want to screw it up with a
breakfast okay you want to go as long as
you can without eating very very
important so the lesson I learned is the
breakfast is not the most important meal
of the day okay and number five I know I
would I was recommending low fat or lean
protein bad advice very bad advice I
just pretty much picked it up from what
I was taught but I never personally
evaluated to see if it actually worked
or not and you want to go a little bit
higher fat not crazy but you want to go
a little bit higher because fat is very
very important to satisfy you to go from
one meal to the next so you can do in a
minute fasting to provide the fat side
with vitamins essential fatty acids this
is very very important especially for
losing weight and also looking good and
being healthy okay and fat is the only
two macronutrient that doesn't trigger
insulin now you've heard of the glycemic
index which are all the foods that will
spike insulin and they rate those on a
scale
but there's also something called the
insulin index okay which is all the non
carbohydrate foods that have an
influence over insolent okay which is a
little bit different and it just so
happens that fat is very low on the list
the more pure the fat is the lower
influence it has over insulin and this
is why fat is actually okay to consume
especially if you're trying to lose
weight okay that's number five now
number six was this I was not focusing
on the history of the patient I wasn't
focusing enough on diving in and getting
clues from a stubborn case whether it's
weight loss or some other problem and a
good lesson to learn was is to take a
good history especially asking the
client when did you start having this
problem when did you exactly start
gaining weight and or having a stubborn
metabolism and then what happened just
before that that is such an important
question that I don't know a lot of
doctors don't ask that question you're
gonna get all sorts of incredible
valuable data that's going to actually
help you solve the case now whether it
was a pregnancy a trauma a stress event
you a change of something changing your
diet you can get valuable data to
actually revert that or change something
or alter something and I'll just give
you an example so someone came in and
they they tried everything it couldn't
lose weight and they've done every diet
they can't even actually lose weight on
a 500 calorie diet right and this
person's been everywhere they're very
frustrated so I asked them when did you
start gaining weight and she said I was
always overweight okay well always yes
my whole life even when you're an infant
she said well no I said okay what at
what age did you start getting weight
and she said when I was five I go thank
you so you were skinny when you were
four she goes yes okay we're getting
somewhere I said now what happened right
before you started gaining weight like
when you're four or five and she started
looking and reflecting and she does you
know I had really bad asthma I said oh
okay
and they gave me steroids hello that's
the clue right there it was the steroids
steroids will really induce a spike of
cortisol and make you fat
especially at early age so then we
started focusing on the adrenal glands
and trying to do things to undo that so
unfortunately there's not enough doctors
that dig into what happens just before
you had this symptom and then using that
data they just go right for the remedy
very very important lesson that I
learned from that ok so number seven
omitting the getting healthy first so
it's not lose weight to get healthy it's
getting healthy first then lose the
weight ok so let me tell you when I kind
of stumbled on that concept which is an
important lesson I had a person come in
to my office
choose the daughter of one of my staff
and she was 320 pounds she was young
girl early 20s and she basically has
tried everything to lose weight
nothing's working of course she went
back to her old habits which is
basically she didn't even eat in the
morning but then she pigged out in the
at night and just ate a ton of junk food
like massive amounts so she was very
very large so I put her in my program
she's totally willing the first month
she loses zero weight ok now I went into
a severe depression I was very
frustrated I'm like you lost nothing I
felt like a failure but she didn't seem
to be upset she was actually ok with it
and I'm I was very surprised and I said
are you ok with that she goes yeah I
feel really good now I just feel really
good I have so much energy
look at my skin look at my fluid is
better and I'm like wow interesting so
she stuck with it another month ok so
after a month - she lost 21 pounds okay
I'm like wow that's cool right so she
stuck with it in month 3 she lost a
total of 63 pounds from 0 to 63 and 3
months ok and I had this incredible
realization that wow you're getting
healthy first you have to get healthy
now this way it just hit me like a ton
of bricks was a light bulb that went off
what an important lesson but all these
cases that I thought were failures were
not failures it was working I just
didn't give it enough time now if a
client doesn't know that and they go
into this program and they don't see
results within the first week as far as
weight loss results they're gonna get
frustrated and quit when in fact it
could be that it was working it just
they just had to give it more time okay
so the lesson to be learned number seven
is to focus on the health indicators
energy level cravings gone stress level
better those things are important
whereas some people trying to lose
weight and they don't know this and
let's say they feel like crap they're
tired they still crave but they're
losing weight it's sort of right and
they're exercising like crazy and
they're stressed out they think that's
healthy no you have to go with the
health because healthy bodies will
eventually lose the excess okay anyway
thanks for listening guys I appreciate
your attention and put your comments
down below
hey guys so there's a whole bunch of
people that really need this information
so press the share button and let's get
it way out there